Where a practice level
quality metric is of concern,
the next step would typically be to
drill down to the individual providers
to see who might be
the source of the problem.
So PoP Health provides data
at that level, as shown here.
We see providers, and within them we
see the actual individual persons.
Here's someone who's doing very well
on this screening metric for tobacco.
Here's someone who's doing not nearly so
well.
Even though we're working at
the population level, the results can
be aggregated and reported for
an individual patient as shown here.
Such a report could be reviewed
as part of a patient visit and
makes the patient status easy
to encompass at a glance.
Care outside of guidelines is flagged
here in red, to make that obvious.